how can we expand upon the lore of the
nutcracker we need to have
well how about there's another realm
there's like two realms like no not
enough around at least there's at least
three realms shut up steve four realms
four take the
yeah
tom can you tell us about a disney
live-action failure that people probably
forgot about
i get two and whether they forgot about
him or not probably has
a lot to do with how old they are or
whether or not they've
suffered a head injury the the first one
the big one was uh
it was a result of
this magical time about 10 years ago
before
disney had movies for boys
uh
and they wanted them they wanted they
wanted boy movies something fierce but
they didn't have a star wars yet and
they didn't have a superheroes yet so
they had to kind of come up with their
own solution
yeah
so instead what they uh so what they
decided
and what all little boys love i think
you'll agree
is adaptations of edward rice burroughs
novels
around 1913.
so they
[Music]
so disney made this book called uh
several things called john carter of
mars initially and then they made an
animated movie that failed pretty
spectacularly called mars needs moms and
they were like well i guess people just
don't like movies with mars in the title
what's that so they changed the name to
john carter yeah yeah uh
actually another one of the biggest box
office disappointments of all time
as 21st century
stories
with a confederate captain as the
protagonist go it's
pretty good it's pretty good
thanks
there were a lot of things people
pointed to is the reason that the movie
didn't work uh
on paper it probably should have it was
being directed by the guy who made wally
and uh and finding nemo
uh
it it had
a pretty good script a huge budget it
was it was pretty beautifully shot uh it
did
star
not one but two of the uh
characters from
x-men origins wolverine which might have
been short-sighted
taylor kitsch
taylor kitsch who uh i had a buddy a
couple years but who uh who did like a
perfect taylor kitch impression late in
in any role that he does
was it just a a guy talking i don't
understand how you do a perfect taylor
catch impression it's
it's just this you just
uh yeah and that's right that's that's
definitely tim reagan's face if you do
that through the whole movie yeah yeah
anyway uh the movie ate it really hard
it was it was
depends on who you asked it was
somewhere in the range of 250 to 300
million dollars to make this movie with
like an extra 100 million uh that went
into
uh uh advertising it
uh
flopped terribly nobody saw it it wasn't
bummer
i did too yeah i thought it was fun uh
it
was
fine i think i came out of it saying
that was okay i guess
yeah that was that was my reaction i was
just like all right
it was acceptable i don't remember i'm
sure i had specific criticisms at the
time but it was
a long time ago so i don't remember any
of them
it's been a little while this was 2012
you would have been
49 at the time i just turned 49 in 2012
yeah
back when my memory was good
right now don't remember those days
can't imagine
uh so that that was a huge drag uh
and then a year later they they had
another one another movie that was uh
kind of in the same vein which was uh
the lone ranger it was gore verbinski's
follow-up to the pirates of the
caribbean movies
it was very much uh a matter of like the
pirates movies just turned into like the
biggest franchise in the world so maybe
if we just do the same thing again
literally the same thing by throwing
johnny depp back into it yeah
this time they put a bird on his head
true this time they put a bird
it's very much like that yeah just put a
bird on it
put a bird on it
oh
boy
um and starring
army yeah yeah
yeah before we all know before we all
knew that dude was up next yeah
in a way
it's really good that this movie tanked
because otherwise disney might be stuck
with a big franchise with a star
who well let's just say less than
employable right now yeah without going
into the details i mean that depends
entirely on several things the uh
fascinatingly the villain in the movie i
don't know if either of you saw it is a
cannibal uh
it's just an extra layer of difficult to
wash it stop it it's added
into
uh returns to the lone ranger
it's like two and a half hours long it's
beautifully shot it's it's it's a
gorgeous movie but uh
impossible to get through
really really boring but like hans
zimmer did the score it's beautiful like
the the the landscapes that they shot
are are
just incredible and like i i don't know
everything about it from a cinematic
perspective just beautiful but uh it's
about an hour too long
and uh we we were just entering the the
phase of uh hollywood history where
johnny depp was no longer
uh fun
right uh
it's uh what historians refer to as uh
the great depression
yeah it was was this about the time that
he started pulling a brando and refusing
to learn his lines and he had to
reportedly wear an earpiece
and be fed this was exactly around that
time that's why he had wild hair
dangling
i don't know according to legend
those are my picks uh
both remarkable in their own right both
uh
immense failures luckily they also both
came out around the same time uh that
the avengers did so everything was going
to be okay for disney yeah because
disney did just fine right by the end of
the day yeah
don't worry guys disney will be okay
yeah
somehow
star wars i think it later the same year
yeah my pick is in a similar vein where
when you mentioned you know disney
trying to get movies for boys
it was the sorcerer's apprentice
starring
nick cage and jay baruchel i think
that's how you think it is i believe so
i
wonder where that guy is
he's right behind you
there he is
[Laughter]
perfect
um i watched this movie thinking how bad
could this be it's probably fine it's so
boring
yeah
it's not even fun bad it's just boring
like you're just like oh my god is it
done
one reason in particular i was
interested in watching this movie is
because they filmed
a very small as it turned out portion of
it
in the studio of wfmu which is my
favorite radio station of all time
they're a new jersey-based freeform
radio station the country's oldest radio
station if you
haven't checked out wfmu check them out
anyways radio uh today's episode brought
to you by
no but there's a scene that takes place
inside a radio station like i think the
college radio station i was hoping i was
gonna get to see
more of fmu and they just it was just
like three seconds i was like i watched
this whole thing so this explains
brian's vendetta against sorcerer's
apprentice as he thinks the radio
station should have been featured more
prominently
he went into it wanting to watch a
documentary about a radio station and
he's like oh it's it's just change and
sorcery it's magic and explosions it
sucks
they eventually did release a
documentary about the radio station it's
very good it's called sex and broadcast
is it better than sorcerer's apprentice
it's much better
so no okay but here's the other thing
right here's the other thing about this
movie it starts so jay barachel's
character dave
very magical name yeah yeah dave dave
the sorcerer he's a student at at like
nyu or something and he's a science guy
he's into science he does science and
nicholas cage shows up and he's like i'm
a sorcerer you're a sorcerer you might
be the
the true merlinian or whatever it is
um and at one point he says like
uh dave asks
so sorcery is it science is it magic and
nicolas cage goes yes
because he's trying to say like it's
both it's science and it's magic and so
once you realize that you can become a
true sorcerer okay whatever so the whole
like the whole magic powers are based on
like i guess like believing in yourself
really good
that's like that's it that's the whole
thing and for the long for the whole
period the whole movie he can't figure
out he can't do it he sucks at magic he
can't do magic you suck you suck you
suck it's no good i guess because he
doesn't believe in himself well enough
and i'm thinking this whole time he's a
science guy right he's going to beat the
bad guy at the end using science
he's going to use science he's going to
show that he doesn't need magic to win
the day because if you believe in
yourself
with science
or whatever you know like use what you
know if you believe in yourself with
science fiction
power his real power is science it's set
up at the beginning he knows science at
the end he should use science and at the
end it's just like oh no you can just do
magic now so like there's this part
where he's doing this like a high
haidukin from street fighter yeah you
know he's like
and he's like holding back this big
fireball that alfred molina is sending
at him and or no it's um it's some lady
it's a magic lady i think it's morgan le
fay the whole movie sucks it's not good
it ends with him it ends with him just
like i am magic after all
and i'm like
no you start with science and with like
me like that's your setup yeah there's
your payoff it's not hard it's the
willow problem all over again like i
mentioned in a couple times ago where
you start off with the disappearing pig
trick you end with the disappearance
right trick it's a great way you set up
a payoff yeah you set up your payoff so
check out science didn't did not make a
reappearance in this building
like the lesson that magic was the real
magic all along yeah exactly
yeah
it's magic so
it was so lame so yeah if i'm like i'm
sure that it's like if you put it on
it'll probably like entertain you enough
it's probably not the worst movie ever
but it's just overall it's disappointing
and it's not like it's not like the
recipe isn't there like who wouldn't
want to watch a franchise of live-action
sorcerer movies starring nicholas cage
as a weird scraggly like that sounds
very appealing to me
you know yeah so
missed opportunity agree there so that
was my pick
nina what what did you pick so it's
tough cause you guys have outlined some
pretty
clunky stinkered movies uh and i don't
think my pick is necessarily a bad movie
and i think that it it deserves an a for
effort but it was a certifiable box
office bomb for disney um and i'm
talking about the 2018 adaptation of
madeleine l'engle's a wrinkle in time
which
i have a friend who likes the expression
two plus two equals fish to explain when
something should absolutely work and it
somehow just doesn't and
this is a great example of two plus two
equals fish because you have ava
duvernay a brilliant filmmaker who uh
directed selma a great documentary
called 13th
and
she
uh pivots this story to be about a young
black girl who is bullied at school and
looking for her astrophysicist father
you know
the character of meg murray is never
given a racial identity in the book so
it's a great opportunity to be a more
inclusive story for people she cast
people like oprah and mindy kaling and
reese witherspoon and just uh
google raw who was justin loki a litany
of very very good actors
and it just
this should have worked and i remember
being very excited to see it and being
like oh that was okay it's not a bad
movie but it's not
it's not as good as it could have been
uh the cgi definitely could have used
some
work it's weird to me that in 2018 like
the cgi managed to be so clunky um
just i mean as a as a refresher wrinkle
in time is about a young girl i believe
she's 13 years old also has one of the
best opening lines in literature it was
a dark and stormy night great opening
yeah um and
so meg murray i love that book yeah i i
read the entire book i saw that the
movie was good i read the entire series
i don't think i even heard that it came
out right yeah i read the whole series i
was hoping this would get spun off into
all of the sequels because the sequels
get real weird with it and they're a
delight is the scene is the first sequel
called like a crinkle in time
you bet it i actually don't even
remember the names of the sequels to be
honest with you
it's
she's very smart she's feeling isolated
at school she's having kind of a tough
time and she's also dealing with the
fact that her father was a famous
astrophysicist has vanished and these
three
like
alien astrological beings uh and they
are mrs witch mrs what's it misses who
played uh in that order by oprah reese
witherspoon and mindy kaling appear to
her and they basically bring her like
across the astral plane to help try to
track down her dad because he he was
basically sucked into a vortex i don't
know it's been it's been a long time and
the movie did not make that any clearer
to me but yeah i mean this should have
been
a great reintroduction of classic
children's book
to a whole new audience and it should
have spawned i think
i believe it's three books that follow a
wrinkle in time should have spawned a
franchise and uh it cost let's see i've
got the numbers right here
yeah it cost about 130 million to make
and it
made 130
or no i'm sorry 250 million
including marketing and production to
make and it
uh only made like 130 million dollars so
pretty bad loss for disney um
and the reviews were mixed too so it's
not like it was you know really beloved
but people just didn't go to see it it
was it was not
it was an unqualified not success like
pretty much across the board which is
qualified uncertainty yeah yeah
um what suddenly there was a word for
such a thing
that's why they pay me the big bucks to
write and edit guys um
that's why but yeah it should have been
it should have been really good and i'm
still kind of bummed that that it just
didn't come together that two plus two
somehow equaled fish in this equation i
hate it i'm still curious to check it
out and i i you know i probably will
eventually but one movie that's that's
on our list of uh disney's biggest
live-action failures on looper.com uh
that i am it's one of those things that
it's like the stone protectors for me
where i see it and i go oh i know
exactly what you did here and i want to
see this because it looks so dumb is um
the nutcracker in the four realms
oh yeah when the trailer for that came
out i got so excited because i was like
oh this is just one of those terrible
ideas that made it all the way to the
thing i have never understood why they
keep trying to make movies out of the
freaking nutcracker it is the worst it's
a nutcracker horse material
it's a delightful ballet yeah that takes
place at christmas and they're like
what if we take this ballet for
christmas and stuff it full of the lord
of the rings what if we take
it's so confusing yeah it just looks
completely insane to me like it's when
the trailer came out i was like oh no
and i haven't i haven't dived into you
know what the nutcracker needs more
action scenes that's what ballet needs
yeah how can we expand upon the lore of
the nutcracker we need to have
how about there's another realm there's
like two realms like no no not enough
around at least there's at least three
realms shut up steve four realms four
take the realms to the max yeah i used
to i don't know how many realms i used
to be in the nutcracker when i was a kid
and i guarantee you it never crossed my
mind as a child for whom this movie is
is meant for to be like i want to know
it's more
i want to know what the four realms are
what are the or is it like candy
i don't know
that's not part of the original case
brian they didn't teach us that with the
ballet the corners of the candy land
yeah okay wait i'm looking on with you
are they like i need i'm trying to think
of a good joke and nothing's coming into
my brain okay
the land of sweets sure candyland the
land of snowflakes uh
the land of flowers i was gonna ask if
it was flowers yeah and the land of
amusements
how is amusements not all of the other
things combined
candy is not a music are the realms at
war also
i don't know
what are the realms doing that is of
such concern to us tom you have a
question
go ahead yeah yeah well and also like
what happens if these the what happens
if they wipe each other out if if the if
the realm of sweets and the realm of
flowers go to war and they kill all of
each other like how does my life change
the next day
i mean i will say it's admirable more
sweet and no more okay it's admirable to
take a ballet where the plot is the girl
gets a magic nutcracker and then all the
mice in her home become giant and try to
murder her and then she takes off in a
flying sled with the nutcracker who
becomes a real boy who is a prince and
watches flowers and candy and things
dance around for her amusement
uh
to try to make that even weirder is
quite a feat and so hats off to the
director of this film it's just it's
just one of those things where i feel
like if you if you were at home
and you're like brainstorming an idea
for like your your next ya novel yeah
you're gonna put up on like wattpad or
whatever you're like uh what if we take
this this public domain idea and we make
like this whole like wizard of oz type
thing like okay that's fun that's cool
you could get some like a decent book
out of it maybe but you know that's
clearly not what we're looking at with
this movie no this is a this is a film
that someone cooked up there like uh uh
nutcracker doesn't cost anything to use
that's a free ip let's use that yeah uh
so that's the part that i think you
nailed yeah
she wants to do something
uh dress her up like a fairy i don't
know uh
four realms morgan freeman get him book
him great give him an eye patch right
doesn't he have an eye patch in this no
i haven't seen it nobody knows brian
nobody saw the movie it's one of those
it's one of those ideas that when you
see it again like i said about stone
protectors you could just see the
cocaine on the board
yeah just like everyone's just like this
is gonna be great we're gonna be so rich
let's do it and the fact that this made
it through several different gatekeepers
at a production company like everyone
involved was like yeah great idea let's
do it let's do it that's crazy they're
like planning out the sequel the fifth
realm yeah you know like
united
[Laughter]
nut
foreign
was gonna be uh the disney plus
saturday morning cartoon show
there's a squad of guys that put nuts
back together
[Laughter]
thanks for watching don't forget to hit
like and subscribe so you don't miss a
single episode thanks for watching we
love you goodbye
[Music]